thank you for that introduction hello
everyone i'm excited to share with
everyone this presentation today
and sharing with you how we have been
working very hard at agilent to
continually innovate and make huge
advances with our hardware and software
with the advancements that i will share
with you today i hope
it will allow you to see how we are
removing barriers and simplifying
workflows with a smart icpms
if you haven't heard the news we are
very excited to announce that we have
just introduced our new
agilent single quad icpms to the agilent
icpms portfolio of instruments
this is the new single quad which is
called the 7850
you can see where the 7850 fits into our
icpms agilent family
it is replacing our old 7800 icp ms
so let's get into the new features of
this new instrument
so what is new on the agilent 7850 icp
ms we have heard from many of our
customers that they want us to help them
reduce time along the icpms workflow
so we have come up with with smart
features to help make that happen
some of the new features are a
streamlined mass hunter user interface
for faster method development we also
have standard uhmi on the 7850
we have improved our maintenance and now
we have better scheduling of maintenance
events
we've also made automatic post-run
performance checks
and we have extensive range of support
services and i'll get into examples of
all of these in the coming slides
in the theme of saving time for our
customers we know that developing new
methods and learning a new instrument
can be very time consuming especially
for those new users or the labs that are
new to icpms
therefore we have a preset or
pre-developed methods or we've come up
with templates for many of the common
methods that are used in the icpms labs
some of them are the drinking water
method the epa 200.8
also the wastewaters
which includes solid waste which is epa
6020
as well as u.s and china pharmacopoeia
and low medium and high matrix samples
templates
we also have method wizard optimization
and we've pre-written some sops to help
you saving time when writing up
documentation
so mass hunter version 5.1 is the latest
instrument control in data analysis
software solution for our icpms this
latest version signifies one of the
largest user interface overhauls since
the original mass hunter version
which replaced the chem station more
than 12 years ago so this new software
is going to look so much better and so
much more improved for many of our icpms
users and we're really excited to share
this new software with you today
so this new 5.1 completely changes the
user interface and workflow we have new
productivity tools we have improved icp
go and a new help and learning center
which i'll show you in this talk today
so the completely new user interface and
workflow
looks like this and so the new
task navigator is a top-down approach to
instrument control method development
and sample measurement it's a simpler
and intuitive task flow for method
development and significantly easier to
learn for our users
the instrument status indicator is a
color coded ribbon along the right hand
side of your screen you can see it has
green we're showing yellow here and then
red
it's very easy to understand instrument
status at a glance
so now let's hear about the task
navigator on the new 7850 from our
agilent icpms software manager from the
uk mr glenn woods
amongst many of the design improvements
mass hunter 5.1
introduces the task navigator
this provides a top-down approach that
instrument control
method development
calibration
qc setup sample measurement and data
analysis
mass hunter 5.1 also offers redesigned
tasks within the method setup
so let's take a tour through the task
navigator the first item is the
dashboard and this displays the current
instrument status
and the early maintenance feedback
categories for our method setup this new
screen displays our acquisition mode
peak pattern number of replicates and
sweeps per replicate we have options for
auto tune generate trim report and
acquire pa factor
batch comments can be set and advanced
acquisition is still available on this
screen we also decide on the type of
analysis we wish to perform whether we
include intelligent sequencing if the
option has been purchased and also
semiquant or intelligant analysis
here we can select our report templates
and define any
other advanced acquisition parameters
tune modes takes us to the redesigned
yet familiar tune screen
element selection is now much simpler as
a lot of options have been moved to
instrument setup sample introduction
takes us to the peristaltic pump or isis
program and features the intelligent
rings and preemptive rinse options
the analyte list defines which elements
sub uses internal standards or analytes
the calibration list allows setup
of the calibration standards and qc
control standards
semi-quant analysis allows the setup of
a dedicated semi-quant method
or whether we use intelliquant
for the quick scan data
the qc parameters depends on the option
selected during startup
without intelligent sequencing the
standard qc parameters are displayed
should intelligent sequencing be enabled
the qc parameters then displays our
intelligent sequencing options
following this is our sample list
and acquisition queue
once the sample list has been created
and the method has been saved
that particular batch can simply be
added to the queue for the next row
thank you glenn
so glenn as our software manager has
been working hard on the software for
for a while now and so it's really nice
to have him
help introduce this to our customers
okay so another completely new user
interface and workflow solution is that
we have now
the pre and post run checked
so the pre and post run performance
verification
is now available and so this is allows
you to know the instrument performance
and the status before turning on the
plasma
the performance criteria checking during
startup and now at the very end of the
day means that you know the instrument
state at any one time
knowing the instrument status after the
whole batch finishes has been or allows
you to know the performance and verify
the instrument condition before turning
the plasma on the next day
we've introduced a couple of new icons
as well too so you can see now we have
the performance check and you can see we
have a run at end as well and so you can
see we have examples where we see
no it was not run or yes it was run and
if this is passed or if it failed
so these pre-run and post-run
performance checks
are configurable targets
so you can see we have a pop-up here
where we can show you if maintenance is
right
so usability was key for this new
software and we know our customers will
love this new feature called smart emf
or smart early maintenance feedback
this is a simple intelligent feedback on
the instrument's maintenance
requirements
and similar to our icp expert software
which if anyone is an icp oes user they
will be familiar with our icp expert
software
so we have used now smart meters
and our smart emf provides operational
insights which allows for reduce
reducing planned and unplanned downtime
and maintenance
you can see that we have customizable
settings where you there's multiple
configurable meters so on the bottom
right hand side you can see in that red
square you can see the current values
and the limit values for multiple
different checks you can see some of
them like clean sample cone clean
skimmer cone etc the limit value is
something that can be changed
depending on the lab environment
let's take a closer look
so this again is the same as the icpms
expert and we decided to incorporate
this into the mass hunter software for
icpms users since it's so popular with
our icps icp oes users
so we've installed
with sensible default settings and these
can be again changed changed when
required by the lab there's multiple
configurable meters we have user meter
options
and important items such as vacuum
system pump are on settings
so you can see on this table here what
this would look like we can have things
in the red when they need to be checked
when they're in the yellow when they
need to be maybe take a take a little
glance at them take a closer look and in
the green means things are good and you
know we haven't been running for very
long
okay so let's hear again from glenn
woods about the emf on the new 7850 for
our agilent icpms
the new smart emf includes new sample
counters enhancing the metrics used for
scheduling maintenance
the meters include sensible default
action values
typically for high matrix samples
and can be optimized by the user for
their particular workload or sample
types
the only fixed maintenance items are
those for the four line pump and cannot
be edited by the user
other than reducing the time between
scheduled maintenance
smart emf in icpms mass hunter uses the
same code base as that in icb expert
and will be very familiar to icp oes
users
operation is very intuitive
and a simple traffic light colors makes
understanding when and what maintenance
needs to be scheduled without any
surprises
smart emf provides instrument insights
let's take a look at some examples
on this screen here you can see eight
meters are laid out
with varying different colors and
varying different levels of maintenance
requirements
in this example we've set the change
sample upper take tube to 200 samples
clean the cone to 300 samples and clean
the skimmer to 350 samples
this gives us an example
of the different color schemes used for
the early maintenance feedback counters
let's take a look at changing and
setting those counters up
by going over to settings
this opens up a separate dialog which
allows us to alter and refine any
particular maintenance items or meters
there are several user-defined options
available in all of the different
counters and metrics under solutions
measured there are some sensible items
and defaults and of course a
user-defined value can be easily set up
to add or remove a particular meter
you simply take on the check box
so i'll add
two more items
they're then displayed on the main
screen being the dashboard this is the
first screen the user sees when opening
mass hunter importantly the meters will
arrange themselves in order of priority
so we can see here action needed earlier
to action needed later
smart emf
really helps provide instrumental and
usage insights thank you glenn
another new feature that i'm super
impressed with is our help and learning
center within this center we are able to
search and find information on anything
that we need to know with our icpms
one thing i really like is the
interactive troubleshooting tool
and the very very clear pictures that
help you figure out what might be going
on with your instruments and any issues
you might be having
and just because i like his british
accent so much uh one more time let's
hear from our software manager glenn
woods about the help and learning center
on the new
5.1 software
help and learning center
as part of agilent an atomic
spectroscopy divisions aims to provide
the most feature-rich yet easy to use
software and hardware
icpms mass hunter includes a completely
new help and learning center
based upon browser technology this
cutting-edge tool significantly enhances
the way users interact and diagnose
hardware and software issues should they
arise
not only does the help and learning
center provide a base for all user
manuals
it provides access to many tools
including
a learning center
a how-to and help
troubleshooting
and maintenance tools
let's take a look at some examples
what's new in icpms mass hunter
is a self-paced course allowing novice
and experienced users alike
to self train on the new version of
icbms mouse hunter
navigation is easy
either by clicking upon the shortcut to
the left hand side
or on the arrows to go through each of
the different course materials
underneath troubleshooting there are new
set of interactive tools that allows the
user to troubleshoot and sort some of
their own problems just by answering a
few questions and performing some of
their own tests
we'll take you through the interactive
low sensitivity troubleshooting tool as
an example
[Music]
the help and learning center also
includes several instructional videos
for items such as routine maintenance
[Music]
the help and learning center is a new
and very useful tool
support of agilent's icpms systems
thank you glenn that is going to be
super helpful for all of our customers
and even for the agilent employees when
we need to look things up as well
so another important feature that we
want to highlight is our new
intelliquant
for icpms so inteliquan is a fast
automated semi-quantitative analysis
which provides greater sample insight
and confidence into results that you've
collected on your icpms
so we know that many laboratories are
under pressure to increase productivity
to reduce costs and to ensure that they
have excellent data quality we've
already told you how we have done some
things to help with this like we've uh
we have preset methods we do auto tuning
for you we have our helium mode we have
robust plasma we now have a standard
uhmi on our 7850
but something even newer than that is
now our intelliquant
so let's learn a little bit more about
how intelliquant is going to help you
so first what is intelliquant well it's
a function in our mass hunter software
that provides extra insights into
samples with minimal additional time or
effort
so to do an intelliquant scan it takes
an additional two seconds of sample
for up to 78 elements so just think for
two more seconds you get data on 78
elements that's amazing and i'm sure
that everybody could spare two seconds
to get that much more additional data
so intelliquant uses helium cell gas
because largely analytes are free from
polyatomic interferences and we can
ensure that we have high quality data
so what can this intelliquant data
provide
well like i just said it can provide
approximate concentrations for 78
elements including those which are not
included in your quantitative method
so if you were doing a method let's say
you do a method that runs maybe four
elements 12 elements you know it just
depends on your laboratory and method
needs
well you could get an additional
data on all 78 of those elements
again for just two seconds
it can it can help you with
identification or confirmation of
elements not included in the
quantitative method that may be of
concern
or interest from a quality control or
safety perspective
it can also help you with estimation of
your total matrix solids or we call this
tms of each sample that you run
this can really help when you're trying
to identify the cause of different
matrix matrix effects
it can also give you information about
potential spectral interferences by
letting you know if there's rare earth
elements for example in your sample and
maybe you're trying to measure arsenic
or selenium and you know that rare earth
elements when they're doubly charged
can have an interference on arsenic and
selenium
so these intelliquant functions
again are automatic calibrations for
semi-quantitative results so we get
these results in the form of we can get
them in the form of a heat map shown on
the bottom right hand side we can also
get outlier information and again these
total matrix solids information
so another very nice feature is the
intelliquant automatically selects the
appropriate calibration from the
quantitative method to calculate
accurate response factors
before we didn't have this function so
this is a new function for 5.1 and it is
definitely definitely useful
so let's take a closer look at this
periodic table heat map for display
you can see that the heat map provides a
clear visual overview of the
concentrations of different elements
that are there in your sample what we're
looking at here is a periodic table heat
map of a powdered donut sample that i
ran
and one thing that's interesting is you
can see
that you know if you take a quick scan
of this you might be alarmed
why would we see titanium
in powdered donuts well we know
since we purchased those powdered donuts
that there is titanium nanoparticles
used in the sugary coating that's on top
of those powdered donuts so this just
further
solidified some of the results that we
might have seen
that might have been surprising
like i said you can also
do outlier results so the outlier flags
are based on the relative intensity of
the analyte mass and the potential
interferences interference source so
they indicate potential overlaps rather
than
definite interferences
the flags prompt the user to review and
confirm any results that could be
affected by unusual matrix components so
ensuring that false positive results do
not slip through unchecked
the tms calculation does not include gas
or solvent elements such as argon
nitrogen oxygen carbon
phosphorus and sulfur and the different
halides to ensure a more accurate result
in the example shown in this picture the
internal standard signal was lowered in
sample four and five
this is indicating a sample matrix
effect in these samples
the change in internal standard is a
useful diagnostic tool particularly when
batches of unknown samples are being
analyzed
so you can see by having these
additional semi-quantitative results
um we get a little bit
extra
confidence so this intelliquant gives
extra confidence in the results
especially when analyzing completely
unknown samples
another useful feature is the isotope
fingerprints
so here you can see we have a full mass
spectrum which can then be checked
against natural isotope abundances
templates to confirm the presence of
certain elements if we take a look down
here you can see that we have different
colors that are being used to lay a
fingerprint over the different isotope
patterns of different
metals
so this light teal color is showing us
the isotope fingerprint or pattern of
iron the yellow is showing us cobalt the
purple is showing us nickel the red one
is showing us copper and the green is
showing us zinc
these intelliq
semi-quantitative results
are shown here for nist 1643e
water srm
so you can see how good of a recovery
recovery we got
using just in telequan this two second
scan these were the results you can see
they're definitely
i think everything was in plus or
minus
um about 20 with a couple outliers you
can see that strontium was a little bit
lower
and
um iron is a little bit higher but this
is amazing for being able to get all
those elements in just two seconds
so in conclusion you can tell that those
two extra seconds are going to give you
a lot of extra data when you have that
intelliquant feature turned on it gives
you insight about your samples to get
the right answer it provides information
about what's in an unknown sample to
maybe assist with method development it
can help you with troubleshooting
and it can provide possible unknown
interferences
okay so let's see how we can use this
7850
for our water analyzer for an epa 200.8
method this is an environmental
conference and this will be a very good
tool for a lot of you listening today
so our agilent icpms water analyzer is
effortless analysis and sensational
results
so it doesn't matter what your
experience or expertise is in regulated
water analysis
by icpms we are here to help you and
however much you need help
so we offer multiple options you could
be a very experienced lab and you just
need a new instrument and we can do that
we can provide you with the 7850
if you need an instrument and maybe some
additional help uh maybe with an icp go
we can do that
we could also help you with an
instrument an sop and an icp
okay so let's see how our multiple
offerings can help your lab just
depending on your needs
so option one would be i just want an
instrument perfect we can
set you up with a 7850 ic
if you need an instrument only this has
been the traditional way that things
have been done in the past if you just
need to buy an instrument that's no
problem you'll still get all the
expertise from us here at agilent
with your
single quad icpms you'll get the power
of the collision reaction cell the third
generation for helium inter interference
removal
and you'll get um our fully featured
mass hunter icpms controlled software
which i just went over with you in this
talk today our new 5.1
and you'll get the highest sensitivity
and dynamic range for the best detection
capabilities
if maybe you need more help
we have maybe you need an instrument you
want simplified workflows but you
already have your own sop no problem we
can go with the
7850 and our icp go
so you'll get the 7850 icpms
you also get our icp go which is simple
fast and easy
all the software is done for you in a
matter of hours not days
but you could use your own method
templates and sops
and with the go you can go anywhere so
you have instrument um your instrument
can be accessed and controlled remotely
from a pc or a handheld tablet or device
such as an ipad or an android tablet
if maybe you have more needs maybe you
you haven't
i have an instrument and i want
simplified operator workflows i can use
create edit my own method templates
no problem again we can just help you
out with an icp go
so with just icp go it is a very easy to
learn it includes templates or you can
import your own mass hunter methods and
templates
it is simple enough to learn in a day
actually
this reduces the cost of training new
users and new analysts and allows
operators to switch between instruments
very simply
you can go anywhere with this so a lot
of times our users they can set up their
instrument you know prepare all the
samples rock all the samples and then
start the start the run and then go home
for the day and be able to monitor
things um from their tablet at home or
maybe they have to go over to another
lab but just want to
monitor things they can do that as well
or even from the comfort of their own
office
it's very simple
maybe your option four though and you
want a complete epa 200.8 solution as
maybe you have little
things currently in place and maybe this
is a new analysis for you
if this is the case we can do icp go
and a full
implementation service
so with this
you would get
your
7850 icpms and all the necessary options
and
supplies that you need
so this is a very low risk solution
because it's being created by the
agilent icpms experts so it includes
preset method templates all consumables
and sop documents already done for you
and that means that you
save a lot of time and money on training
costs so the icp go software with
workflow design for the contract labs
will already be set up for you
and this can be done in
as little as a few days
so this comprehensive on-site
implementation assistance
with agreed analytical performance
targets can be set up by our trained
engineers and just a few days
so just depending on what your needs are
and your flexibility we have many
different options to get you up and
running and to help you simplify and
save time with your epa 200.8
analysis
so now let's take a little bit closer
look at this icp go which i've been
talking about in the last few slides
so icp go is a simple workflow based
software interface for our icpms this is
something that our software team has
been working on for quite a few years
perfecting so that our customers can
save time and money
this is designed specifically to meet
the workflow requirements of routine
production labs running standard methods
like epa 200.8
this is a browser based
it is controlled by the the instrument
can
can be accessed and controlled remotely
from a handheld device
that controls that has icp go
installed on it such as an ipad or an
android tablet
it is very intuitive it is very fast and
easy to learn and we've been told that
people are already being productive on
day one
so icp go can help but what exactly is
icp go
so this simplified control and analysis
software um can be used on a 7700 a 78
7850 7900 and an 8900
it connects to your icpms via a simple
web-based interfe
interface
uh this can be a local pc it can be a
networked pc and it can be a tablet
device
so it makes things fast and easy so that
you can get your work done
so let's take a closer look so this
browser based connectivity and control
you can see that we have our icpms which
is connected to our mass hunter
workstation
this can connect by a web browser or
instrument control pc
and then we have this local web server
this web browser can be connected to a
device
such as windows
or
operating software
or
android software
or your mac software
so it's very simple and has a logical
workflow so first you log on with your
password
you can then check your instrument
status
you can build batches from your template
you can put things in the queue
you can monitor your batch or your cue
process as well as your qc actions and
make sample changes
and then at the end you can even review
your results
so your icp go can bree can be
pre-configured and or customized batch
templates
you can create these uh
in your analysis batch
so you can use your agilent supplied
batch templates or create your own from
masshunter
and you can see the batches created from
different templates can be queued for
automatic or sequential analysis
you can easily manage your analysis in
four simple steps first you create your
sample
you can import or edit your sample list
you can check your method parameters if
you need to
and then you can cue your samples and go
simple
so it's also compliant with qc checking
with or without intelligent sequencing
which we just talked about today
so your results include color-coded qc
flags which can be monitored in real
time at the batch level or at the queue
level it's up to you whatever is easier
and detailed outliner information can be
held at the touch of a screen
you can also check to see if your
samples are in place
so it has a touch friendly interface
it's configurable and easy to understand
you can edit your samples at any point
you can see here on the screen you can
just hit your edit batch
even if you need advanced qc that is not
a problem you can use your advanced qc
functions with icp go as well
your samples at a glance no problem
if you need to change the order of
different batches that you have in the
queue no problem you can see how you can
change the order of things all from your
icp go
if you need to keep an eye on your data
while you're busy somewhere else you can
also do that as well you can see on the
screen you can just toggle through
no need to be in the lab you can control
this from anywhere and just take a quick
look to see how things are going you can
see we purposefully made something flag
so you can check to see
you know if your qcs are passing or
failing
maybe you have a flexible workforce
where you want different users on your
team to have different access that's not
a problem as well you can have different
people being allowed to
have different access
to methods and parts of the software
i hope i've shared with you how fast and
easy icp go can be for your lab and
really got across to you that it's the
fastest and easiest icpms software for
the routine lab
that it has a user interface that has
graphical and minimal learning curve
that it's browser-based that it's touch
friendly can be used on multiple
different traditional or tablet devices
it's flexible secure you can have
multiple users with different levels of
use
and you can connect from anywhere where
login is available so with icp go it is
very simple
so thank you so much for all your time
today i'm so excited that you joined us
and that you listened to this talk on
the 7850 our new single quad icp ms as
well as all the new features that we
have um with the
new software
mass hunter 5.1 so i know that was a lot
to cover today so please reach out to me
or anyone else on the agilent icpms team
if you want more information about
anything that we covered today
or
maybe you would like a live demo of our
new 5.1 software because it also can be
used with your other agilent icpms
instruments like your 7800 your 7900
your 8 800
in your 8 900 so again thank you so much
and
we look forward to hearing from you